[Music]
in money-hungry news ooh I'm money
hungry my money's very hungry submitted
by rose milk tea oh that's pretty good
that's one of our options at our drink
shop called sip really mm-hmm you're
gonna be getting one very soon well one
day we're having it delivered no you
ordered blueberry whoo y'all should
order that it's really good I did sip
sit sit you're gonna have a Chinese
accent afterwards Oh Oh that'd be so
dope if we could advertise that dude
every time you sip you become more and
more Chinese sucking shorter I was
wandering around the mall like this was
holding my head back so [ __ ] funny
dude they're having a broken arm in like
well they've been alive so long they've
been alive I got hurt in 70 years she
starts hitting her head oh my god she
likes to do we're at a restaurant right
ah my head huh it's just talks [ __ ]
like this [ __ ] dandruff flakes just
play sexy run from this sexy baby
no I'm saying she treats that shoe like
a broken PC dude some uber drivers are
reportedly scamming passengers with fake
vomit charges what whoa why I never
check my charges I know that's why
they're w/o there's a bomb in charge
they could charge you anywhere between
50 to a hundred and fifty oh I think at
that horn a nose cards a pop-up like for
me it pops oh it does no no no not
through BRR but like my credit card oh
can we bill them for the real seamen we
leave in there the jackoff charge yeah
hey guys I just want to send you this
$20 invoice came a little in the back
seat you're welcome yeah welcome there
is a huge difference though between lyft
drivers and uber drivers though really
they're usually the same
I like live times they signed up for
both they can be but you can only be one
or the other you can't have both apps on
at the same time Oh [ __ ] a lift
basically people yeah but the lyft
drivers dude they're a little
interesting compared to my uber drivers
leave it to me give it to me what uber
drivers are the car seems to be a lot
cleaner and there seems to be a better
scanner for a vehicle on uber I like to
and they stocked with waters and God
like I've had some weird ass lift
experiences like I put it on my
Instagram recently where this dude was
[ __ ] driving like 90 miles an hour he
black blasted trance music and his whole
car had under glows everywhere oh [ __ ]
it was if he was on ecstasy for a guy
who didn't speak any [ __ ] English and
the dude just kidding but and he had the
windows down throughout the whole ride
oh yeah bro Rana excuse me excuse me but
I'll be blown back by the [ __ ] I
couldn't even do anything you know it
was like that old Beau's commercial
remember [ __ ] you yeah he was just
blasting it and then at a certain point
I was just cracking up so much I didn't
say anything okay this is hilarious does
it be funny just to like document so I
put it on my instant Horry it was
[ __ ] wild man you can't hear [ __ ] cuz
of the window yeah and he was into the
muted so much he missed the exit by
three exits hey that means though he did
it on purpose cuz chi-ching yeah that
money it was said Christ oh it was a
price was he finally as cheap while
driving
it was [ __ ] wild dude dude you gotta
get a lot of unnoticed a lot of these
drivers are farting in the car more -
than me yes absolutely which has become
more like I mean that we're gonna like
nobody's gonna be like um like you just
get in its and this like is have to
pretend it basically sometimes is
pretending that nobody farted for like 9
or 15 minutes you know it's like a like
just like yeah it's just gross just like
Cash Cab kind of but with just farts and
no money I love I love - cab that's my
[ __ ] house cabs a game show one of the
craziest lines I've ever heard from a
from a lyft driver that I got was this
fool is driving so insane who's hitting
on you
no he started like [ __ ] moving left
to right because he was swerving so hard
you were sliding across the seat yeah
and I broke can you slow down yeah and
he was that okay said would you like to
get that all the time or safe I'm like
the only gave me two options I was like
put them together on time and safe like
what the [ __ ] man
no dude almost died or just later yeah
[ __ ] picky [ __ ] that would be
a way better service almost dead or just
late yeah [ __ ] was wild dude you got
armor what time when that old taxi
before they do brought fell asleep in a
taxi after a bar that dude just kept
driving bro that's fun I woke up like an
hour later it was like a hundred and
forty bucks right and the dudes like
where are we going
you know there's no destination huh true
I got into [ __ ] passed out but he
started the meter uh we settled on a
hundred bucks I paid him a hundred bucks
yeah wake you up I was trapped dude
it was [ __ ] on that's [ __ ] up it's
like Natalie Holloway did did you get
swindled when you went to Europe by
those people who grab your bags and just
drive you to your spot and it cost hella
money yeah everybody when we first first
got there with Kiki's parents these grab
bags huh yeah they just grabbed on
they're just like oh and then they drop
us off there like 150 hmm what's that
like in Europe like they'll don't do
that where these guys will come up
there's helmet there's how the do is to
just post it up if someone grabs my bag
I'm [ __ ] bush in a mob yeah but
sometimes they're not grabbing their
bags they're just like they blend into
little build a newspaper with like a
drivers hat are they wearing like a suit
they might be oh they're super blended
in so they just watch people come in and
then you happen to you then I see I mean
I from I got street smarts so I can just
see and smell it but then if you don't
you're then you're just like oh come on
feel I'll give you a ride and it so
anyone that's Czech friendly for me
online no no I'm gonna get my own cab I
want someone that's resisting me cuz I
know that they're real
but in those guys are just there reading
a newspaper in little oh I'll keep your
I'll give you right and those are the
guys are scamming it yeah I'm not street
smart but I'm just a big [ __ ] that's
fair
now then the next time we went through
the airport we saw that same guy that's
Camelback [ __ ] holding up in his ass
down why is it a scam though are they
not drawing for the airport but are they
don't work for the taxi he had his own
van like we're yeah but they take you to
the hotel right three times the price oh
but what happens is like what happened
then so you and a couple of my other
friends where they told us the same
[ __ ] story guy comes up come here
come here and they just grab all their
stuff and throw it in the car and they
tell him to get in the car and they take
him to their destinations and they're
like oh how do they know where to go
well that you tell them but they don't
know what's going on they just think oh
this is this is how the airport work
yeah and when they're grabbing it it
doesn't seem like they're stealing from
you it just seems like a team or a
stream hospitality so it's easy for you
to give in like oh cool just gonna take
my bags awesome yeah look aggressive
team the next time we're like [ __ ] these
guys know like the price that we're
gonna get it was half the price you
heard last time yes I took the airport
taxi that's what I always do cuz you
could trust the airport taxi that super
shuttles crazy do you ever take super
shuttle no what is that it's like some
guy picks you up with like nine other
people in the van right everybody's late
right oh you gotta go bro there's no
time to dawdle bro shuttles cheap - yeah
it's like six bucks dude is that that
blue van with the yellow letters yeah
you get there but like you have eleven
new people oh and they came and picked
us up here yeah but that we were the
whole shuttle so that was cool yeah yeah
yeah we had to shuttle oh but those guys
they go all over LA and then they're
just rushing and then they get to the
airport oh yeah when your shuttle you
time it with your thing so they'll get
you there on time no wonder that dude
was sweating our super shuttle drawn up
will sweating balls can you just drop
people off some ubers like it smells so
bad in there like some people like they
have food they've been eating food or
they
they smell like honey yeah like 31 hey
while he was growing mushrooms in his
[ __ ] glovebox dude like a little like
lights in there and he had [ __ ] soil
and his go up Bob [ __ ] terrarium bro
you party bro and I was like sometimes
he said he's like he just opened the
glove box and they had yeah a little
terrarium in there whatever it smelled
like yeah farm if you ever get a bird in
France I would [ __ ] [ __ ] the French
bro the French sucked it nobody likes
the French eh shut it down baby don't
think you're live crazy it's they don't
use AC and so your windows down the smog
is [ __ ] nasty and they don't [ __ ]
be complete [ __ ] bro damn I don't
have the French yeah I guess I've just
been there like I've been there a couple
times and you but they get offended if
you don't call them [ __ ] though so
like you have yes drivers were actually
French though I like American they were
like yeah different kinds like Eastern
European it's Indian all kinds we have a
really bad news hole the Middle Eastern
food in [ __ ] Europe though is the
[ __ ] it is it really on that swarm of
[ __ ] yeah it's fun good good man yeah so
back to this uber vomit fraud so now we
were saying that they're gonna be
cracking down on this alleged how do you
improve it to exactly like what are the
JPEG JB yeah yeah unless you keep a fake
like a you know a big thing in back of
the ladle of [ __ ] vomit in your trunk
is an uber driver fake vomit you know
what more people just [ __ ] puke in
their own backseat and take a picture of
it no no it's like some of it seems like
what they do is like they just like
spill water or whatever and then they'll
add some like yeah tilapia tilapia oh
yeah like there was this one writer who
said in the same night he got charged
$300 total for with two different uber
drivers for these cleaning fees I don't
like
who should it be driving with a stomach
flu there I've had some decent nothing
laughs this is my fake photos little
Molly than the guy kept it for me
goober driver dude in Europe where were
we Rome yeah in Ramallah Oh camera that
look like this not this one but we left
it in a [ __ ] cab and then the cab
driver came back no he was super ninja
Penn is the best I left my camera at the
data store that fool ran two miles to
give me my camera back it's close like
Casey left his wallet in the in a taxi
in Japan he never got it back Wow
like what oh wait why would they do that
employee chased me down I thought he
thought I seized Olson called the camera
we love it well actually no because we
forgot which cab company away like you
how do you remember right knees love to
be helpful man you could uh yeah they
get robbed be most when they travel
apparently they do yeah because they
don't understand have street smarts
because they don't need to be like they
come from like the safest country and
they trust people yes you have cuz you
could trust people in Japan if you need
help or whatever people will help you
out yeah she was thrown up all over
Japan and they were helping around yeah
up in the cellar you really got yeah we
should have thrown up in the [ __ ]
Hoover
[Music]